So going back to our mani-core challenges, we have seen that when the number of
cores grows, so does the coherence traffic on
the chip. And for that, we needed a
scalable on-chip network such as a mesh, and
the directory coherence, which we have already seen
in our cache coherence lesson. Another thing that
having more cores will make more difficult is
that as the number of cores goes up
the off-chip traffic that we need goes up. To
have decent performance we will, as we increase
the number of cores, increase the number of on-chip
caches. So if we have four cores, we
have four level one and possibly level two caches.
When we have 64 cores, we'll have 64
level one and level two caches. So each core
doesn't really generate more misses, but it generates the
same number of misses regardless of how many cores we
have. So we have the same number of misses
per core. So as we have more cores, the number
of memory requests which is what we do when
we have a miss, would go up in proportion to
the number of cores. Now note that the number
of pins, the number of those little wires sticking out
of a chip, does go up slowly but not
in proportion, or anywhere close to in proportion to
the number of cores. So if we double the
number of cores possibly we get maybe 10% more
pins but that's it, because these pins have to
physically be large enough to not break when we
are moving the chip around and plugging it into
a motherboard. So what happens is we get some little
improvement in off-chip throughput while our demand for
it basically grows in proportion to the number
of cores. So our off-chip available throughput becomes
a bottleneck. So we need to reduce the
number of memory requests that we generate per core and the way we do that is
to make the last level cache, which in
most two day's processors is the level three cache,
shared so that all cores go to that cache and
its size is shared equally by all the cores. And
the size of that cache needs to go up in
proportion to the number of cores as it goes up.
So as we double the number of cores we should
at least double the size of the last level cache.
But there is a problem to having one huge LLC
like this. Such a large cache would be slow, and
if it's really one single cache, it will have
one entry point where we enter the address and
expect the data out. And that entry point needs
to be somewhere on our chip that now possibly has
a mesh or another advanced network. And that means
that that one point will be where we send all
of the level two misses, so it would become
a bottleneck. Pretty much now we don't get to use
all of the links equally. This set of links
that go to this entry point for the cache will
get much more traffic than the other links. If
we double the number of cores, then those links around
the entry point get double the traffic. So what
we do is we don't have just one big last
level cache, we have what is called a distributed
last level cache. Now let's see what that looks like.